We think of wars as relatively uncommon but
that couldn't be further from the truth.
Since the end of the Second World War there
have been over 250 major wars worldwide.
That equates to almost four wars per year.
But war isn't a new problem invented by the
stresses and tensions of modern day life.
Over the past 3,400 years humans have only
been at peace, entirely without war, for 268
of them.
To put that into perspective, humans have
only been at peace with one another for 8%
of recorded history.
All this fighting doesn't come without a heavy
price tag.
Wars are ridiculously costly, both in cold,
hard cash and human lives.
But what is that price tag?
Let's find out the real cost of war once and
for all.
Let's first try and work out the cost of war's
ugliest side effect, human lives.
Every war has a different cost; so for the
purpose of illustration let's examine a recent,
well documented war, the Iraq and Afghanistan
war on terror.
A long, large scale and horrendously expensive
war that began in 2001 following the 9/11
attacks.
Which, to some extent, still goes on to this
day.
The number of estimated deaths of the Iraq-Afghanistan
war between 2001 and 2014, are as follows:
Yes that's right.
In most wars the majority of casualties are
not from the armies themselves but civilians.
And those numbers are only the deaths caused
directly by conflict.
They don't include the thousands of other
indirect deaths caused by side effects of
war such as disease and famine.
The majority of civilian casualties during
the Iraq-Afghanistan war were caused by anti-personnel
and anti-tank mines as well as ground attacks
from insurgents.
There’s no denying that the human cost of
war is immeasurably horrific.
So let’s take a look at the second facet
of wartime expense, the monetary cost.
How much money do you really need to go to
war with another country?
Again the answer entirely depends on the scale
and nature of the war.
So let’s once again use the Iraq-Afghanistan
war as an example.
Why?
Because it was the most expensive war of the
past 50 years.
It is estimated that by the time it’s over
the Iraq-Afghanistan war will cost a whopping
$6 trillion dollars.
To put that into perspective.
$6 trillion is enough money to feed every
single starving person on Earth for 200 years.
Just to clarify; with that money you could
feed a billion starving people every year
for the next 200 years.
But it’s not quite as simple as sending
all that money to Africa.
The majority of the money the US used to pay
for the war was actually borrowed, mostly
from China.
The George Bush administration estimated it
would cost between $50-60 billion to invade
Iraq and overthrow Saddam Hussein.
That’s considerably less than the total
running cost as of today.
So what went wrong?
What were all those six trillion dollars of
taxpayer’s and borrowed money spent on?
Well the thing is they haven’t actually
been spent yet.
To date the US has paid $1.6 trillion towards
the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan.
That includes everything from military equipment,
firearms, training, wages and hiring third
party contractors, among other things.
It’s estimated that the cost of keeping
a single American soldier in Iraq or Afghanistan
for a year is $3.9 million.
So where does the other estimated $4.4 trillion
come in?
That comes later.
The biggest cost of a war is not the war itself,
it’s the aftermath.
Especially when you borrow most of the money
you used to pay for the war.
The majority of the money used to pay for
the Iraq-Afghanistan war was borrowed and
there’s a big load of interest to pay on
top of it.
The interest is so great that over the next
few years the repayments will tally up to
several trillions of dollars.
But there’s an even bigger long-term cost,
veteran care and benefits.
970,000 veterans of the Iraq and Afghanistan
wars have registered for disability claims.
Over the course of the next 50 years payments
for the care and welfare of all those veterans
will bring the total cost of the war up to
an estimated $6 trillion.
But for every soldier who fights in a war,
for them, the war never ends.
In 2012 more veterans of the Iraq and Afghanistan
wars committed suicide than were killed in
action.
This isn’t a new problem; more veterans
of the 1982 Falkland’s war have committed
suicide since the war than died in combat.
War has many evil facets and whether it’s
a medieval battle or a modern-day high tech
skirmish, you can always count on two things.
The effects will be catastrophic and the costs
will be outrageously high.
But wars don’t have to be expensive.
In 1920 the British forces defeated the Dervish
forces of Mohammed Adullah Hassan, who was
more commonly referred to as “Mad Mullah”
amongst opposition forces.
Britain’s resistance against the 20-year-old
Dervish forces was known as the Somaliland
Campaign.
It came to a climax during the fifth and final
war of the campaign in 1920 when the British
Royal Air Force accompanied by Britain’s
Somaliland Camel Corps (yes that was actually
a thing) defeated the Dervishes’ stronghold
in what was then known as British Somaliland.
This war has gone down in history as “the
cheapest war in history”.
Costing a grand total of just £77,000.
Which is about £3.5 million by today’s
standards.
That sounds expensive, but it’s actually
really bloody cheap.
Most wars cost in the region of several billions
to several trillion.
If most wars are so expensive and cause nothing
but turmoil and sorrow then why do we have
them in the first place?
It’s widely debated that wars don’t actually
solve any problems.
After all we have only been without war for
8% of recorded history.
If wars solved problems wouldn’t that mean
war would become less frequent?
When in reality the opposite is happening.
With 250 wars in the past 70 years it seems
that wars only create more problems and subsequently
more wars.
Many people believe wars are strictly for
profit.
Yes wars are costly but they also put money
into many pockets, namely arms and military
vehicle manufacturers.
When the cost is human lives it’s saddening
to think that some people are profiting from
it.
It truly is a sickening thought.
But whether profit is actually the main contributing
factor to starting a war is a topic of much
debate and controversy.
Every war is different, sometimes it’s driven
by profit, and other times it’s just the
perverted fantasies and disillusions
of
a doomed soul.